guess what the minimalists are going on
tour with a live version of the
minimalists podcast
and i want to invite you to join us for
a night of less find your nearest city
at the minimalists dot-com / tour we'll
see you there
how can you keep a very small wardrobe
from feeling boring or uninspiring
without having a lot of accessories with
you yeah find your excitement outside of
your closet anyways please don't rely on
your clothes to be the the spotlight of
your life dude you know what we have
that essay that you wrote Josh food is
not entertainment maybe there's
something there with clothes are not
entertainment right yeah
clothes we often think of when we think
I don't think that a project 333 or a
capsule wardrobe is inherently boring
though and I think that's so that's a
misnomer that people often place upon
thrust upon it it is but what's
interesting and maybe this hasn't
happened to you but I know it has
happened to a lot of people and it often
used to happen to me where I would be
bored with my clothes or bored with my
wardrobe and that would be my trigger to
go shopping right and what I discovered
during my first three months of not
shopping at all is I still got that
bored feeling but because I didn't like
satisfy it immediately I discovered what
I was really bored with and it was never
my closet like my closet wasn't the
frustrating thing my closet wasn't the
boring thing so good it was something
else in my life that I never would have
known about because I shut that up I
squashed that feeling by shopping yeah
even if you were bored with your
wardrobe no one else is bored by your
wardrobe most people don't care we we
had a friend you member Nina yeah right
do you remember Nina she was sort of in
the the minimalist community early on
you know if I have to declare a winner
of minimalism I think it was Nina Yau
if she she left everything right she
left everything and like she got down to
like like you know I have 17 items
included her clothes it was crazy and
your toothbrush yeah anyway so she
worked for a I think a pharmaceutical
company or or she worked in HR at a
corporation and as an experiment she
wrote about this it's not available
anymore cuz she took her blog down she's
so mental so minimally she go to her
blog there's only 16 things you can find
her Nina yokan she teaches yoga now in
Chicago but and she has a book called
truth but
what I remember about what she did with
her wardrobe she wanted to prove to
herself that like no one else really
cared about her wardrobe so for an
entire year she wore the same pair of
black pants and a bright red sweater so
it wasn't this sort of boring yeah one
person over the course the entire year
mentioned hey didn't you wear that
yesterday she wore it every day no one
noticed yeah and okay maybe more people
would notice in your life maybe two or
three people if you did that but guess
what people really don't care they're
not bored by your wardrobe right that's
true that's true they don't have time to
think about you yeah if people stop
being my friends for my friend over like
what I wore I would just that's just a
good way of filtering people out I feel
like